something happened yesterday that tells
us beyond any doubt that the House
Intelligence Committee is not going to
be the entity that conducts a full
objective and definitive investigation
into the connections and potential
coordination and collusion between
Donald Trump and Russian agents listen
to this buffoonery Republican House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez started a new controversy
yesterday by saying he believes that the
communications of President Donald Trump
and associates may indeed have been
picked up after the election by
intelligence agencies conducting
surveillance who were these intelligence
agencies surveilling when they may have
incidentally picked up Trump
communications foreign targets now I
don't even know which aspect of this
story to start with Pat I guess to begin
with Devin Nunez didn't go to the
committee
to tell them that he had received this
information from who we don't know he
instead went to the White House to tell
President Trump about it and to the
press
trumpets heard Devin Nunez say hey I've
been told that Intel agencies did pick
up Trump communications they heard that
and they thought Trump vindicated Obama
did wiretap Donald Trump this is a total
misunderstanding not only of the truth
but even of what Devin Nunez is alleging
here because what Devin Nunez alleged
yesterday and still even as of this
morning multiple members of the House in
Tel Aviv said yeah that's what Devin
Nunez said but we don't know where he
got it what he alleged is not that Trump
Tower was being surveilled or that Trump
associates were being surveilled but
rather that foreign targets were being
surveilled and because Trump associates
were in touch with some of those foreign
targets of surveillance some of the
communications were picked up including
Trump associates this is the opposite of
vindicating Trump this is bad this means
that as an example imagine that US Intel
is surveilling Russian agents Russian
targets and they're listening to Russian
communications and all of a
sudden a Trump associate gets on the
phone with one of these Russian agents
this is the opposite of Trump being
wiretapped by Obama so number one we
don't even know if this is true pad
number two
Devin Nunez who's supposed to be
investigating Trump is going to the
White House to tell Trump what
information they have and number three
even if true it's bad for Trump yeah it
really makes you question where his
interest lies if he's going to go to the
White House instead of his own committee
first I'll say I mean even even assuming
it to be true if we take both what
ranking member shifts said to be true
and what Devin Nunez said to be true
what's the bigger story here that the
Obama administration did something that
was legal but perhaps maybe unpalatable
to the American public or that the
there's direct evidence that Russia
colluded with the Trump campaign yes
once an impeachable offense and ones
just kind of disabled one is legal
surveillance right and and again
surveillance we could argue is unethical
on some level or not useful on some
level but again legal surveillance but
here's where it really went bad again as
soon as Nunez finds out about this he
goes to the White House to personally
briefed Donald Trump on the revelations
after talking with the press but without
having shared this information with
Democrats on the house Intel committee
the guy supposedly conducting a full
fair and objective investigation of
Trump collusion with Russia hears
something and goes to the White House to
disclose it to the subject of the
investigation I'm at a loss for words
this is not someone that can conduct
this investigation and even John McCain
is saying we need an independent panel
here and the press is treating this like
it's a huge story because Trump seems to
feel like he's vindicated over this yeah
I think all the attention should really
be on what ranking membership had to say
because lutely
both are just accusations both are just
words at this point absolutely what
Schiff had to say is the big story and
Adam Schiff also saying this is a cloud
over the investigation now this isn't
going to get us in a fair investigation
we need an independent comedic committee
immediately and in addition of course to
the FBI investigation that FBI director
James Comey confirmed is taking place
you are going to have a house panel look
into this you have to at least pretend
like it's a fair and objective
investigation and at this point
Devon Nunez cannot be the chair of such
an investigation because it's abundantly
clear that he's a trump surrogate
running to trump to tell him what they
have at every opportunity but again you
have some trumpets who think that what
Devon Nunez said vindicate strums
Trump's baseless allegations that Barack
Obama wiretapped him it does no such
thing and I genuinely believe Pat that
there are trumpets who having heard what
Devon hoon has said will actually think
Oh Obama did wiretap Trump and that's
not even what's being alleged here right
because they won't keep up with the
story and see if it actually gets
validated and what the evidence comes
out with when they're done with the
investigation yeah it's always the
headlight the the misleading headline is
what is in the minds this is why Bowling
Green Massacre from Kellyanne Conway was
still probably effective propaganda and
disinformation from the Trump campaign
even though it was a completely made-up
and fabricated terrorist attack this
stuff works
and I guarantee you we've interviewed
some of them that there are trumpets who
think Trump was right Obama wiretapped
him that's what Devon Nunez said
yesterday send me your thoughts about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show